OK, so I'm going to try to get us caught up
on some of the Donald Trump events of the
last 72 to 96 hours.
There was a lot of craziness during the tail
end of our vacation.
Donald Trump continuing to hold rallies as
if there were no pandemic, often with hundreds
or thousands of people, many without masks,
mostly without masks.
Sometimes the people on stage behind Trump
do have to put masks on.
But the rallies range from horrifying to authoritarian
to dystopian to perverse and everything in
between.
There were notable rallies in the past few
days in North Carolina, Minnesota and Nevada.
I'm going to highlight different things in
different clips, notably the North Carolina
rally on Saturday, which is where we will
start.
This was post the death of Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
The country learned of the death of Ruth Bader
Ginsburg during Trump's Friday night rally,
which I will get to this rally.
You will see a whole bunch of nonsense related
to our IBG.
So let's go through the key moments.
Trump having notable problems speaking during
this one, even worse than the ones earlier
in the weekend.
Here is Donald Trump, who has had a renewed
focus on the moon and Mars lately, saying
that you need the United States will be the
first station to put an astronaut on Narz
with an N..
Take a look.
Well, and the first woman on the moon and
the United States will be the first station
to land an astronaut on Mars, on Mars.
We have Trump actually just really struggling
to put together a sentence.
A number of verbal glitches at this one here.
Is Trump short circuiting on the word sanctity?
Just really odd, almost like he choked on
his tongue.
He will defend the dignity of work and we
will defend the same sanctity of life.
Then Trump struggling with Nobel Peace Prize
several times, calling it the Nobel Peace
Prize and then getting all mixed up and discombobulated,
not clearheaded, covered.
I got the Nobel Peace Prize nomination, a
Peace Prize Nobel nomination.
And then before we move into the meat of it,
here, he is saying his own name wrong when
you say your own name wrong.
That is another level referring to Don Tunneled
prompt.
Donald Trump is OK.
I was the first time anywhere.
Donald Trump.
I love Donald Trump.
Yeah.
So not going well from the standpoint of verbal.
One of the sickest moments, Trump having his
supporters vote by yelling as to whether they
would prefer that he replaced Ruth Bader Ginsburg
with a man versus a woman.
It's almost like a deleted scene from Saturday
Night Live where they said that this is too
stupid.
Well, it's reality.
So women and men ready.
Would you rather have a woman on the Supreme
Court or would you rather have a man ready,
a woman or a man?
So would you rather have me choose this very
scientific.
Actually, it's a lot more accurate than these
polls.
That interview, like ninety seven people have
been interviewed.
Then, you know, they judge a million dollars
and they probably don't interview the people.
They sit behind that desk and just say, would
you rather have a woman on the Supreme Court?
Yes.
WOMAN Yes.
Thom Tillis says yes.
So would you rather vote, oh, would you rather
have a man on the Supreme Court?
Everything is a game.
Everything is a joke, a contest.
It's unserious in some way with Donald Trump
still on Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Early in the rally, Donald Trump fed the line
to the crowd, fill that seat, kind of telling
them it didn't naturally surface.
Donald Trump telling the crowd the chant now
is fill that seat.
And then Trump here in announcing that he
will run in saying that he will announce Ruth
Bader Ginsburg's replacement this week or
potential replacement.
The crowd getting going with fill that seat.
And by the way, we have plenty of time as
a lot of time.
You know, you're talking about you're talking
about January 20th.
Here's a video of Donald Trump telling one
of those inane stories about people referring
to him as sir.
It's notable, but this one is that the crowd
is almost completely silent.
Trump's going on and on the crowd not even
remotely keyed into what the hell Trump is
talking about.
Check it out.
An almost completely silent crowd.
The crowd is so quiet when one person reacts.
When one person laughs.
You hear them.
You hear that?
Stand out.
Take a look.
Five point seven billion, sir.
I said that's a lot of money.
It's actually two planes.
You know, Air Force One is two planes.
I'll give you a little.
They're going to say that's classified information.
They've been flying around with two planes
for 30 years.
So I assume somebody's going to our Air Force
One is thirty one years old.
Right.
So, you know, look, it's time.
A lot of the Arab sheep ships come in.
I see that plane.
They have a brand new one.
I said, what do we have?
Thirty one years and we're protecting them.
Why the hell are we ever doing?
So I said so they finally had thirty one years
old.
The new one, suddenly different 747.
It's much longer, bigger wingspan, much more
beautiful.
You know, it's modern.
It's beautiful.
Five point seven.
So I said to the head of Boeing, nice guy
Dennis.
This was before they had the difficulty, which
is terrible what happened.
But that went on for a few minutes and really
relatable.
Right.
Like billionaire president complains that
Arab chics have much nicer, newer, private
airplanes.
Then he gets to fly around and really a man
of the people.
Then Trump sort of laughed about how MSNBC
reporter Ali Velshi was actually hit by rubber
bullets while covering protests, refers to
him as a CNN reporter.
Details don't matter.
Ali Velshi is actually with MSNBC.
Trump again with a completely silent crowd
behind him.
No first grade teacher has ever been able
to accomplish this.
Trump gets a huge crowd of people with low
attention spans to actually sit completely
quietly.
We'll see.
They lined up.
They went down.
There was no social distance again between
these great tough guys.
There was no social distancing.
Tom, tell us.
They went down and they had like two hundred
fifty thousand dollar outfits and more crap
and they all met with night goggles.
And these guys were sort of, you know, white
guys shouting at them, screaming at them.
They were screaming at the wrong people.
They went down.
They never had a stop.
It was just forward.
It all ended.
It all ended in Minneapolis.
It took you also at, what, a half an hour?
Remember, they hit the CNN reporter in the
knee.
He went down, Ali Velshi.
He said this is a friendly protest.
It's wonderful to see such a behind him.
It was all fire for blocks.
It looked like Berlin during the war.
This is a friendly.
What are they doing?
How does that help to be like that?
How does it help?
We're joined tonight.
And then Donald Trump rehabbing this conspiracy
theory that Joe Biden got some kind of upper
before his debate with Bernie.
Which is hilarious because Trump's the one
that always seems to either be on uppers or
downers, depending on the day.
Take a look at that.
But don't underestimate him.
Look, he's been doing this for 47 years.
And I got a debate coming up with this guy.
You never know.
They give him a big fat shot in the ass and
he comes out.
And for two hours, he's better than ever before.
The problem is what happens after that.
Now we're going to ask for a drug test.
We are.
I'd like to have a drug test, both of us.
I'll take it.
He'll take.
Because I watched him in the debates with,
you know, with all those people, those Democrats,
Trump initially was speculating, was Biden
maybe on something?
Trump has now moved on with no more evidence.
Mind you, Trump has moved on to saying Biden
got a shot of something which improved his
performance during the debate.
Trump still seems to think that Corona virus
testing causes illness, which is just wacky.
Take a look at this.
David Pakman billion people.
We are up 50 million tests, more than India.
In fact, we're about to crack one hundred
million tests.
And when you test, then you have does this
make sense?
And you have cases.
So we do all this testing and I come home
and I turn on NBC News.
It is so it is so bad.
I think be seen.
That's not only Emma's DNC, I think NBC with
Lester Holt, there's another beauty.
How Lester?
And then it got really weird.
I spent a while on this clip.
I don't know what Trump is talking about.
Trump seems to say that he would give himself
a D as a grade on his Corona virus response.
He never explains why.
And it almost becomes unclear whether Trump
thinks a D is a good grade or a bad grade.
It's a very strange clip.
They stopped it from going into the rest of
China.
Should have been stopped in China to defeat
the China virus.
We launched the largest industrial mobilization
since World War Two.
Somebody said, what grade would you give yourself?
Is that a plus?
But I would give myself a D. I would say I
would give myself and my whole group, because
Mike Pence is great.
Mike Pence really was.
He worked so hard.
It's unfair.
The ventilator's the vaccines, the therapeutics.
Now we have like this Trump.
No, a deal isn't good.
It's just complete and utter nonsense.
And then finally, in this dystopian again,
Donald Trump actually admits he's counting
on the courts to play a role in him winning
reelection on November 3rd.
Take a look at this one.
We're going to have a victory on November
3rd, the likes of which you've never seen.
Now we're counting on the federal court system
to make it so that we can actually have an
evening where we know who wins.
OK, not when the votes are going to be counted
a week later, two weeks later.
But in just three and a half years under my
administration, we've secured America's borders,
rebuilt the awesome power of the U.S. military.
Think of that.
Of course, my reaction is we know we know
you're counting on the courts.
Fortunately, Biden also knows it and seems
to be lawyering up, which I've been saying
for weeks he needs to do.
And then absolute last thing, Donald Trump
made headlines with this saying if he loses
to Biden, he will disappear.
If I lose to him, I don't know what I'm going
to do.
I will never speak to you again.
You'll never see.
I hope that that's a promise that should inspire
us to get out and vote.
So that was Fayetteville, North Carolina.
Brain falling out.
Nonsense.
From Donald Trump.
Then we will work backwards going next
to Minnesota.